war horses have died within five days at
Churchill Downs in Louisville two of
those deaths involved horses trained by
Safi Joseph Jr a famous trainer who says
it's not clear what happened blood work
revealed nothing out of the ordinary
these were not injuries to other horses
including one Derby Contender had to be
euthanized after getting hurt on the
track Churchill Downs put out a
statement that reads while a series of
events like this is highly unusual it is
completely unacceptable we take this
very seriously and acknowledge that
these troubling incidents are alarming
and must be addressed it all brings back
painful memories from 2019 when 42
horses died at California's Santa Anita
Park and those incidents led to some
safety reforms there